it's Josh Norman Washington Redskins
cornerback partnering with Febreze and
Charmin to prepare America to not ignore
the bathroom the one place fans unite
during the precious few minutes halftime
was so naptime chef fritzy is your guy I
appreciate what do people say on the
streets oh man what do they not say
that's the thing they give me the whole
rundown they give it to why I don't know
why it is I guess the media perceives
something and they feel like that is
what it is so they want to put it out
there man it's a lot of Twitter Wars out
there you embrace it though absolutely
you're not afraid you don't watch things
back do you not at all for what have you
ever wanted anything back and say you
know what I went too far with with
something I said apologizing for words I
say because that's how I feel at the
moment how much of your job is being an
entertainer I think it is our job to be
honest with you because we're selling a
product and in that product people want
more of it so they want to see more of
it and the more of the character the
more of the sale of the brand but so you
understand receivers are divas
there's selling products as well
absolutely I mean you got fret on
fantasy football or the main targets is
getting picked up right now look at it
who would be your first pick who they of
course not even a question
not a question I think you definitely
get him I mean the numbers he didn't
putting out the last since he's been in
the league just unbelievable but what
makes him difficult to cover more than
anybody else because he's a physical
specimen I don't think if you look at it
guys that explosive in that big they can
ruin every round on the route tree it's
just you can't find those guys do you
have to interfere with him like how many
how many plays would you say that you're
just holding on
to him you're doing something you could
be flagged for uh of course you can get
flagged
every time six times in one games I can
believe it but hey it happens so I mean
you gotta think about it for three guy
and you got a car that back pillar we
suck if we give a play or kitc oh you
the were so trash man get out of here
get your pass all right come on your own
feelin you see how it is just Julio ever
say anything you know we never talk
nothing
Jim wish that he would talk do i yeah
what we do is I think I like him so much
because he don't talk
oh can we can just let our athletic
ability
like exhale pass the next pass the next
it's just so beautiful it's like artwork
there's nothing like it man
but if I talk all day what does that do
to you
it fires me up oh it does yeah you
playing it to my game but he talking to
me but if Julio talks to you you're
getting fired up no but see the thing is
with him I know his game he's not gonna
talk to you okay so therefore I have to
talk to myself I know he's not gonna
give me nothing so I figure it out
myself
do you ever yell at yourself Oh Tom's
now this is my favorite one of me me
gets beat right you guys always point to
some other DB like no we kind of do
because it's like oh dang this is not
what we drew up in the meeting room man
and we look like where's my help you
always point to the safety always it
goes down here look and we don't know
once it's on the island and then guys
catch the ball on you okay cool that's
on me so I hang my head
I gotta do better but if this is me and
another guy he's going up the middle and
he catch the ball and I look like I'm
the one that's oh it's on oh hey look at
the other guy like they know me joining
us I have your draft profile okay hmm
now this is where you're coming out of
Co is sucked now you were a walk-on at
Coastal Carolina right now your brother
played there yeah so Mario plays there
hmm and you walk on and then all of a
sudden you get drafted do you want to
read your draft profile here now I took
out the positives just so you know Josh
these are only the negatives here
everybody reads it from Tom Brady JJ
Watt they all drew brees here is your
draft profile and you can tell me if you
think that there's any truth in it well
I would say this first and foremost only
thing that matters
was my brother allowing me to come to
his place and allow me to sleep on his
couch while I was going through my
transitioning of kin here well also if
your brother's not there at Coastal
Carolina what do you think happens to
you I would not be at Coastal Carolina
but would you be playing today I would
be playing oh you would okay we'll be
playing they would have sounded more
dramatic Josh this is what real NFL
analyst said about Josh Norman missus oh
wow this is so great okay ready yes my
girl has not faced top level competition
Marc will knee contribute our special
teams to stick which he didn't do that
much at Coastal Carolina so you're gonna
be a special teams guy teams guru in
order to stick that means I had to do
the laundry for the guys which I'm okay
all right how about lack of top speed
may limit him impress man coverage lack
of speed may limit him impress man
covers
hmm these are for three guys and I was a
4/7 guy to come back
were you a 4/7 that's what they say it
so I couldn't keep up with these guys
who was running so obviously I must
sucked give me give me the last line
here just give me give me the bottom
line oh my god can struggle with him and
transition movement to its left hmm yeah
I don't even understand who's coming up
with this list by the way last one is
needs to work on his upper body strength
no no the bottom one give me the last
one that was a bottom character concern
the character concerns regarding Norman
looking across as very cocky at times
okay is that true coming across as cocky
at times I've never met met Einstein
I've never met him I did he is the
greatest minds all time yeah do you
think he was cocky no Michael Jordan yes
the greatest basketball player of all
times do you think he was cocky yes okay
oh wait did you talk Brady let's talk
about him for a moment this probably go
down as one of the goats the greatest go
what's he's cocky
yeah he's cocky okay oh let's move on
Deion Sanders which I don't care for
like that but let's talk about him do
you think he was cocky
wait you didn't like the unstart I mean
yeah really you think what about him do
you think he was cut yeah okay there so
why is it that I gotta take less from
being the best or being the greatest my
position I'm not convinced you people
who wrote that or just plain out a
little bit called him cocky Josh I have
the list of the names of what
they wrote please I'll give it to you in
a way because if kaki is that fine line
of confidence I will take that 110
percent every time because you're not
cocky at what you do
don't do it did you say be allowed to do
you face Brady have I faced them and
preseason and he was freaking on target
is there you're probably saying alright
like if I said yeah Coastal Carolina you
know one day you're gonna be playing
against Tom Brady mm-hmm and then you
get that moment did you have sort of
that out-of-body experience like I'll be
damned there's Tom Brady there Peyton
Manning all that for me cuz he was the
guy was coming in everybody knew I was a
big Colts fan and Peyton Manning and
everything so when I got to face him
when we played I was gonna Carolina and
he was with the Broncos it was just wow
that was the out-of-body experience but
then when we got to the Super Bowl
it was magnified so that was probably
the coolest moment of going against a
quarterback I've ever had did you say
anything demanding after the game
absolutely yeah hey man I need that
jersey
I need that jersey to frame because I
went against my childhood idol way to
Jersey they sent it to me the Super Bowl
Jersey he sent me a Jersey somebody
looking at crowd probably like man I
need that am I gonna sell it no never
ever will I ever do you have a press guy
for fruits eat oh yeah we got a present
for you okay
you have to bring it up okay Oh campaign
that I'm running right now with me and
him together oh my god and there it is
is that the it's the golden toilet and
using this because Charmin and for
breezes put on no this at halftime you
guys was consumed liquids and solids
that's gonna be the most that ever had
in the whole entire year at halftime
you're gonna go to the bathroom and when
you go to the bathroom
you're gonna need Charmin free
yeah people all around your parties make
sure you have them because I'm telling
you golden toilet cheese fresh how
emotional are you getting a golden
toilet I've never seen anything like
that and it's an honor what
pretty emotional moment is Josh Norman
has just added 4cv golden toilet seat
carry on in the plane you know put in
the overhead you need to put in a check
bag because you go through a toilet seat
in hold if you do make sure you tell
them you doing it for Charmian and if
they don't if they don't respect that
then you know then then you're not gonna
I'm playing the halftime show do not go
to the bathroom they gotta hold it I'm
checking another airline
Josh Norlin to the Redskins you killed
it today hey thank you for joining us
man we appreciate that the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]